Hello Freak bitches.
And I became aware of you specifically because of your interview with my crazy
friend Alex Jones.
Oh yeah.
Alex.
I love Alex Jones.
Alex was great.
He had me on to talk about,
I mean this is a topic I'm discussing that is,
is difficult to get people to have you on to talk about it because they not Alex
though.
No,
not
site.
We found more corruption.
I can't believe this is the insanity of it all.
You have to love his passion.
He's a good friend of mine.
I love him.
Yeah,
he is so passionate.
And when you follow your passion,
successful following,
that's happened with,
with Alex.
He's so passionate that people think it's fake.
They think that the like,
he's like some sort of a CIA plant and he's like,
you know,
living this lie of,
it's like the idea of putting up,
I almost wish it was fake that because like I feel,
I always tell them every time I hang out with them,
like you stress me out or just stress like,
like I feel bad for him.
Like he can't calm down.
He's always,
yeah,
he's intense when he's eating hot dogs.
I mean,
need another all fucking hot dog man.
Where's she going with those hot dogs?
Yeah,
he was,
uh,
we came with us to the UFC
great time with that guy.
He was fun.
Dude,
I have to tell you,
after interviewing with him for an hour,
he,
he's genuine,
genuinely cares about the direction this country is going in and he's willing to
put his neck out on the line.
Yeah.
Just like you,
you do Joe.
And uh,
and,
and that's admirable because you're,
you're seeing a lot of people just kind of shut up right now.
Yeah.
It takes the real heroes to really come forward and talk about everything that's
going on or crazy.
That's when people are freaking out of your mind.
Are you nuts
for folks who don't know the story,
the story that I got from the Alex Jones show is,
and this is a subject that I had been really curious about why this wasn't
receiving any mainstream coverage.
When we would see all this coverage,
what was going on in Syria and all this coverage is going on in Egypt and in
Libya.
But no,
we never saw anything on Bahrain.
And uh,
I saw some horrific videos that I found online of just the military
assassinating dissent,
uh,
assassinating a different people that were protesting.
And you,
you look at the video and you like,
how is this not huge?
How was this not all over the news every day?
How was,
how were we not,
you know,
imposing sanctions on his country?
How are we not,
you know,
speaking out against this horrific show of just,
it was just horrifying to watch,
but it was weird how silent the mainstream news was about it.
It was like there was nothing and you ran into this.
Oh yeah.
I didn't only run into it,
I was knocked over by it and run over.
No.
Okay.
They just hire you thinking you're a beautiful woman.
You just want to be like a model who's going to read the news and you're just
going to shut the fuck up.
I think so.
And unfortunately I'm Greek and I'm a Scorpio and attorney.
Yeah.
Is that good?
That's dangerous.
Super Dangerous.
I don't think they,
I really don't think that they knew I wasn't just a talking head puppet when I
was hired.
I was actually hired by someone who ended up leaving the network.
Um,
and uh,
and so,
so I think they were surprised.
Uh,
I fucked up.
They didn't see it coming
in 10 years.
If people go back and evaluate the situation though,
they thought you were going to be a female Ryan Seacrest and just run with this.
Well,
there's a weird trend,
especially in Fox News,
these gorgeous women reading the news.
I'm like,
that is such a sneaky trick because especially if you're a guy who can't get
laid,
like having a beautiful woman talk about anything,
it's like I just want to hear her talk.
I just want to just tell him.
He would tell him what's going on.
And so like what better way to program people for your right wing agenda then
have like the hottest chicks in the planet.
Tell you what's wrong with the left
and then also have them say weapons of mass destruction.
Whoa.
Damn.
And it worked.
You know,
obviously we ended up in Iraq and Afghanistan and they're continuing to bleed
the hot chips.
Propaganda is strong for sure.
Well tell us your experience cause you,
you know better than anyone.
You were working on CNN.
I saw some of the other stuff that you did.
That was amazing though.
Especially the theme of the piece on the child prostitutes in Las Vegas.
So you watched that.
It was hard.
I felt for that mom.
It was so horrible seeing that mom holding one baby,
talking about her other baby who's now 13 and is just running around as a
prostitute.
It was insane.
It was insane to watch.
So I know you did serious work for them and that's like,
that was some really deep shit and it was a long piece.
What is it like to,
to go from that to just running into this wall and this one particular subject
that set you off this Bahrain issue.
Like what was that like?
It works well for me it was really disturbing.
I was,
it was
horrific because I knew these people in Bahrain were being tortured and abused
and um,
and systematically killed and doctors can be killing doctors.
Doctors are taking care of people who protested,
who got shot for the,
for treating these people.
They got tortured.
Yeah,
they got tortured.
Some of them are still in jail.
These are genuinely good people.
A ambulance drivers were beat journalists.
Uh,
one was arrested,
his body showed up a couple of days later,
just full of,
of torture marks.
And,
and what really bothered me is because I grew up in the Midwest and I know how
the American people get taken advantage of and our tax dollars are going to this
bar brain regime to support them.
And they're the ones doing this to their people.
How much money do we send to Bahrain?
Every year we send a,
we,
I don't know the exact amount of money,
but I know that we send more than a billion dollars worth of weapons.
We've given them more than a billion dollars worth of a weapons.
They're using some of these weapons,
some of this tear gas that they're using to systematically gas their people,
which they are doing.
They're taking weapons that they're allowed to use,
which is tear gas and bird shot.
And instead of using those for crowd control,
they're using those to systematically kill their people and gas them.
And this is being made in Pennsylvania with tear gas.
Yeah,
they're there because it's you and approve.
So literally dropping tear gas on these villages every single day,
all day long and night.
And Physicians for Human Rights and Nobel Peace Prize winning organization has
been trying to raise hell about this because it's,
it's tearing up these people's lungs.
People who are as Madec are dying,
elderly are dying,
they're suffocating in their homes and they're misusing this gas and it's a very
systematic way that they're doing it.
People are having miscarriages,
women,
um,
some of these doctors are now connecting it to the tear gas.
Uh,
so,
so this is something that needs to be talked about urgently because these people
as I speak right now,
they're,
they're being guests.
How many people have died from this so far?
Uh,
so far they don't know it because they can't a hundred percent,
uh,
you know,
say you were gassed in a couple of days later,
you die because you have a respiratory issues.
You can't 100% connected to the gas,
but so far more than a couple dozen people have been killed
and they just continually do this.
You continually all day long.
Yeah.
And I think it's a way,
it's a way that they're trying to suppress the protests also a way that they're
trying to,
uh,
to silence the opposition and get people in these and these neighborhoods to
convince the youth to quit protesting because they keep getting gassed.
His,
as a result of it.
What is our business there?
What is our business with Paul Ryan that we support them?
Well,
this means everything to us right now.
And a lot of people will say,
okay,
Bahrain is so far away.
What does it matter to me?
I always explain this to my sister because she's in that mindset.
She doesn't really know about the politics in the region.
Well we,
we keep hearing more and more about Iran and a potential war with Iran.
So we need,
we have a navy base in Bahrain,
in Bahrain is right across a,
there's a body of water separating bufferin and Iran.
So we need that naval base if we're going to go in and eventually attack you,
Ron.
It's very strategic for the u s that's why we have buffering as an ally.
Um,
and so this situation is a situation where the u s is giving Bob Crane money and
keeping our base there and allowing these atrocities to happen because of a
potential war with Iran.
So,
so your tax dollars are going directly to this regime.
Not only that,
covering up the story further gets us into some,
uh,
potential conflict with Iran because you're not knowing.
We're demonizing people who we want to attack.
And then we're,
we're praising people who we want to keep as our,
as our allies,
who we really should probably should be attacking.
Exactly.
If people knew we wanted to stop atrocities in the world,
you wouldn't be looking at a run.
You'd be looking at fucking ball ranch.
Exactly.
You know,
we were detained violently there.
We were thrown on the ground.
We had machine guns pointed at our heads and they tried to erase all of our
video.
Uh,
and this was about 10 a 10 minutes drive from the naval base worth.
15,000 Americans are living and um,
you know,
and they tried to,
uh,
to bury the story.
But,
but fortunately I was with another female producer.
We were able to hide these,
these media discs actually in our,
in our bras during the detainment.
Yeah.
Um,
now that I look back on it,
it's kind of funny,
but at the time we were very worried about that.
The discs falling out is you're laying on the ground and you have a gun pointed
at your head and erasing your video.
You don't want that just to drop out on the floor.
What do you say to them?
Oops.
I don't know.
I came from,
none of my tits
actually got,
uh,
so it was a,
it was a situation that was just pretty eyeopening.
That's intense.
And you tried to go back.
Oh,
I've,
I've tried many times.
They won't let me back.
You go back after that because you find a connection to this story as a
journalist when you know something's happening,
um,
I,
he,
you're crazy.
In other words,
no,
the people are really good people.
When you meet them,
you,
you just remember them.
You,
you hold a,
uh,
a big place in your heart for them and,
and for,
um,
for their survival and,
and you feel duty to tell their story.
What is it about the Middle East that makes these crazy dictators?
I mean,
that's really the last place in the world were due to still rocking it.
Old School like that where there's like a king running a whole country.
There's only the Middle East.
And it's really fascinating when you look at human history and you find out that
that's where the original civilization,
the oldest known civilization as soon mirror,
that's where Iraq is.
So like,
so those people that are,
they're essentially the townies of the world.
It's like people in the Middle East are like these dictators.
I mean they really are running things the way they did thousands of years ago.
They have never had to evolve.
They've never had to move on like the rest of the world has.
So I don't think we can even wrap our heads around the idea of kings in this
country.
It's like it seems,
even though as our police state clamps down on our rights starts slipping away
every day with the more of these insane bills at pass,
I still don't think we understand what it would be like to be under the rule of
Saddam Hussein and having his Uday Day and whatever the,
his other sons name this crazy evil psychopaths,
sons running around torturing and killing people.
I don't think we can even understand that.
I think that's almost outside of our range.
So as long as something like this about rain isn't reported on,
it's not talked about in the news.
We don't have to focus on it.
We don't,
we don't really,
it doesn't,
it doesn't register with us
and,
and we're keeping them in power.
We're keeping these dictators in power.
So that's another thing that I don't think,
um,
our,
our current government wants us to discuss because they don't want the people to
be outraged and make us leave.
And they don't want this protest to succeed because if the protest succeed,
these protesters are going to kick the u s out.
I mean,
the u s has a aided this regime and,
and oppressing them for decades and,
and so,
so that's another reason the US doesn't want this reported on in the mainstream
news.
Wow.
It's so crazy because I guess the idea is by not have taking military action
against someone like that,
you're,
you know,
what,
what are you just turning a blind eye to it or what do you,
I mean,
how do you,
how do you continue to,
how did you know,
send them weapons?
How's that possible?
It seems,
it just seems unconscionable.
It seems like a,
at a certain point in time,
someone has to cross some line somewhere and just go,
what,
what are,
what exactly are we doing?
Like is it really that important to go into Iran that were allowing this country
to run like this?
Like what,
what,
why are we supporting this?
Like what are we doing as a country?
Are we completely about dollar bills now?
Is it just about controlling oil ports and,
and,
and pathways?
I mean,
that's really what the Iran thing is about,
right?
It's about controlling the,
about being able to get oil out of a,
what does that,
that,
that shipping route yes.
There.
And um,
and it's about,
it's about exactly.
And it's not,
don't let people lie to you and tell you it's about,
they're worried about human rights abuses in any Ron because look what we're
doing in buffering in order to potentially attack you,
run where we're helping them oppress hundreds of thousands of people on a daily
basis.
So,
so if we really cared about human rights,
we wouldn't,
we would have left buffering a long time ago.
We wouldn't be sending them weapons
be in Mexico when,
right,
exactly.
And,
and we're being an a and once again,
Joe,
this goes back to the American public being lied to systematically by the media.
And it's a real shame.
I think so many people say,
oh well the Americans are stupid and they don't know what's going on and know
it's Americans are being fed lies constantly,
all day long and,
and it really needs to stop.
Um,
it's,
it's a shame.
Now you were there,
you're inside,
you're on CNN now.
What was it that you wanted to report on that you couldn't,
what was the,
the exact censorship?
What did they tell you what you could or couldn't say about it?
Yeah.
Well,
what happened was once I got back from Bahrain,
um,
they were surprised when obviously the Bahrain regime,
when we started airing this video,
cause we were able to sneak out with the video.
They thought that they had erased all of our video.
Uh,
and so we started hearing these stories.
And at first it was great.
CNN was letting us air all of these.
Um,
and that was for,
you know,
about a week or so.
It's very easy to get coverage on.
But then Barbara and started calling and complaining and their PR companies,
they pay US citizens and US PR companies to do PR for them.
Uh,
the people can't afford that,
but of course the regime can.
And um,
and then,
uh,
eventually three months later,
we finished our documentary and we found out that it wasn't going to be airing
on CNN international.
It aired once on CNN,
us,
but never on CNN international to the target audience,
which is,
is the most,
uh,
the most viewed English news station in the region.
And so,
uh,
we need these people needed to see this documentary.
And it was an airing.
And,
and I've had documentaries.
I've done at CNN,
the dinner,
Aaron,
CNN international,
but this entire documentary was shot overseas.
And what really got me was my bosses directly above me were,
were dumbfounded.
We would have phone calls and emails and people said,
I don't know why this is an hearing.
I don't know what's going on.
Um,
my producers were very,
very upset.
I mean,
they had risks are lives to tell this story.
Our sources had risked their lives to tell CNN their story.
Uh,
one guys who for Doctors Without Borders has house was burnt down after he
talked with us.
And,
um,
and yeah,
I mean in our main source and the documentary,
he's in prison right now.
His mom just died yesterday and he didn't even get to say goodbye to her.
Nabeel Rajab,
he's in prison for the next three years and he's a peace activist who has a
picture of Gandhi on his cell phone.
Um,
and so all of these sources that helped us film this documentary or punished and
harassed for helping CNN.
And so we still couldn't believe why they had an aired it on CNN international.
And,
and so I kept getting people writing me and calling me and telling me,
you need to look into this.
There's something going on here.
There.
It's a,
it's a much bigger story.
And seeing as how I don't have a family and you know,
I'm not tied down to a retirement plan or I really could give a crap about,
about the money.
Um,
I started looking into it and realizing the brain's actually a paying customer
at CNN.
They are literally paying the network for programming.
Uh,
journalistically.
I don't know if a lot of people out there listening know about journalistic
ethics,
but we're supposed to be watchdogs on government.
We are not supposed to accept money from them.
Not only accepting money.
Okay,
that's different if you accept money and you air a commercial.
But they're actually airing our long programs on CNN,
paid for by the buffering regime,
not only Bob rain,
we're talking Georgia,
Kazakhstan and other,
uh,
other regimes.
And this has been going on for decades and it bothers me cause people are being
lied to.
So it's just paid propaganda programming unit for propaganda.
So instead of being the news,
they're there select pieces of information that these governments want Americans
and whoever watches CNN to see.
So they pay them for it.
Yeah,
they pay illegal.
Well journalistically it's,
it's,
um,
I would,
if there were a journalist's police,
I would arrest them.
Uh,
but it,
it is legal,
but is it right?
Uh,
because when the air,
some of these programs,
Joe,
they don't let the viewers know that that's paid for by the government.
Right.
When you watch like one of those wacky fake talk shows where they're selling a
blender,
they have to tell you this is a paid infomercial.
They have to tell you when this,
this blender guys in his talk show,
so showing,
you know,
how you make cucumbers slice real easy and stuff.
They have to tell you,
why don't they have to tell you that on CNN?
That seems way more important than the fucking blender.
Well,
exactly because it's shaping our foreign policy.
I mean,
they're feeding the American public this propaganda so that they think
everything's rosy and happy in Bahrain when really the situation there is,
is horrific.
And if you look at one of these programs,
you can youtube it.
It's called I list Bob Rain.
They have their host Richard Quest.
They have him live at the race track for a week in Bahrain talking about how
wonderful the country is and how progressive it is.
And he interviews the crown prince and calls him a reformer.
And this is the same crown prince who was in empower when troops shot and killed
and broad daylight,
these tanks to shot out into a,
a crowd of protesters and just killed them in broad day light.
This is the,
the prince that two years earlier,
CNN was telling the public was great,
was progressive of reformer.
And,
and it's not fair to the public when you watch these,
the disclosures are so minimal or they're not even there if you go on youtube,
the videos,
you know,
um,
and it's not fair to not only seen as journalists to our sources,
but,
but to the people watching because they don't know they're getting propaganda.
So this has been going on for decades.
For decades.
We haven't had real news.
We've had a mixture of some real news and some bullshit that's paid for by other
country.
Yes.
Look up,
uh,
I list bufferin commercial and you can watch the whole commercial.
And you'll see not once in the commercial that's like progressive,
fabulous new this week we're talking about buffering,
you know,
it never says,
and then commercial that this is paid for by buffering and,
and so it's,
that's not fair to the people.
It's not,
it's not fair to view beyond creepy.
How big is Bahrain?
Bahrain is about the size.
Bahrain is small.
It's about the size of San Francisco.
Population wise,
you can't say Bahrain every time.
Right.
Not going to say Bahrain.
Bahrain.
Okay.
And you know what I mean?
It's like one of those words,
like if you commit to saying it correctly every time,
how do you spell it?
A,
B,
a,
h r a,
I n and m and also we can,
you can see a video of these protests.
They're insane.
You watch them and you just see miles of people protesting and,
and then you really realize this is a true revolution they're trying to have
there,
but it's being oppressed by the United States.
Um,
because you know,
if the people get in power,
they're going to kick the U s out there.
Very upset because the US has,
has kept a regime in power for them.
So we're helping this creepy fuck by giving them $1 billion worth of weapons use
tear gassing people to death.
Oh yeah.
Oh Wow.
And,
and not only that,
they're systematically getting it off the,
the news in the u s as what happens to me it was,
it was,
it became nearly impossible to cut through the red tape.
Well,
this is really disturbing.
If you had any hope whatsoever that we were going to avoid some sort of conflict
with Iran because it seems like that it's just there they are dead set on it.
That's why another reason I came forward urgently and cause this is about much
more than Bahrain and the systematic cover up of what's happening about rain
only tells you what's,
what's potentially going to happen in the future and,
and,
and in the near future.
And that's uh,
an attack on Iran or potentially some people,
if you,
if you go to the far side who have really analyzed this could say this could
potentially become a world war three,
Jesus Christ.
And it's all just to control the oil,
right?
I mean,
is that what's it's about?
it's just a control oil and it's just,
this is the way they've always done it.
So they're going to continue to do it this way,
even though now people are paying attention finally for the first time in human
history.
Yeah.
Well,
they're going to tell you if you talk to people who are very pro Israel,
um,
and,
and once again,
I don't have an opinion on,
on any of that area.
I try to cover objectively,
I've,
I've covered stories in the West Bank and in Israel,
but they're going to tell you that Iran,
uh,
often deny.
God said he will wipe Israel off the map and they're going to repeat that over
and over because that's there for ward propaganda that they're going to start
feeding to you.
And they already have for years.
And actually,
if you go back to that speech that they're referring to aqua dinners,
I'd never said that it was miss translated,
but instead they rolled with that in the u s media has continued to roll with
that.
Watch.
Erin Burnett show.
Yeah,
I've seen the,
uh,
the original one.
They,
when it's translated correctly,
it's a totally different meaning.
It wasn't that we were w but it was,
it wasn't nice,
but it wasn't the same thing.
Exactly.
I think it was in response to if Israel attacked Iran,
you know,
we would wipe them off the map or something along those lines.
Wasn't,
it wasn't that it was Maura.
Uh,
I'm saying that he,
they want the regime out of Israel.
They want that government out.
It was more a rhetorical then than physically,
like we want to go in and murder you all and kill you.
It was more w we want you to be,
be kicked out of office.
So we sort of have acquainted it to like Khrushchev banging his heel,
you know,
saying we will bury you like that.
That sort of a thing that's like,
so we've,
we've decided to run with that is the big threat.
Yup,
exactly.
And they say it's as if Iran gets a nuke,
they're going to send it right in and wipe Israel off the map.
So that's what they're trying to use that for.
And everyone needs to pay attention.
It is,
it is propaganda.
It is forward.
It's just like weapons of mass destruction.
I see them now,
now that I've been in inside,
I know how they start feeding propaganda and this is exactly what they're doing
was saying,
well,
it will be,
Ron's going to wipe Israel off the map so we need to go in and attack and,
and,
and guys,
I mean,
this could potentially get us into a conflict with much,
uh,
more permanent and damning implications than,
than Iraq and Afghanistan ever,
ever wore.
Yeah.
It seems like this would be huge.
This would be much bigger if we actually went into Iran.
It's a,
it's another level of civilization above what was going on in Afghanistan and in
Iraq and theirs does no reason for it.
It doesn't make any sense.
And there's no way the rest of the world is going to tolerate it.
It's gonna be,
it's gonna be chaos.
Yeah.
We have Russia and China to worry about as well.
If we go in and,
and,
and Lord knows what can happen from there.
I just hope that the American people realize that there they are being fed
propaganda with,
with the Iran situation now in the same people behind Iraq,
same forces are behind this push to get us in Iran.
Okay.